all right the oxford dictionary defines
liberty as freedom to live
as you choose without too many
restrictions from the government
or authority well the red state
governors you see right next to me on
the stage tonight they understand the
meaning of liberty they understand why
it's necessary
to have freedom to go to school to
practice your faith to worship to
run a business to choose how you want to
act and live
so why do those who espouse those
traditional beliefs
increasingly find themselves just the
subject of ridicule and cancellation
attempts
and how do you prevent those same
americans from being purged from the
workplace
universities and even the military
governor desantis you've recently pushed
back on this
issue through legislation a bill you
support would punish big tech companies
for
de-platforming conservatives and other
traditional americans
you kind of see this coming i mean the
effort to purge the military of
extremists which means traditionalists
but how do how do americans out there
very demoralize about this how do they
fight back
well we're fighting back in florida so
i'm gonna the bill's passed i'm gonna
sign a bill that will hold big tech
accountable
it'll allow you to sue big tech if they
your urge to platform you
and also produce protections for
political candidate speech
but here's the thing we cannot let the
discourse in our country be controlled
by leftist oligarchs in silicon valley
and that's what's happened over these
last few years silicon valley
allied with corporate media and quite
frankly the the party in power
it's almost like state-run media and
conservatives are seeing we're on the
odd side out so we've got to fight back
and i think this is the strongest piece
of state legislation anyone's attempted
and i think it'll make a difference and
so we look forward to signing that very
soon
governor reynolds a lot of people that
you chat with
they're like i don't want to say i don't
want to talk about my
friend's teacher my daughter's teacher
my daughter's coach
i can't speak out people are afraid yeah
i've never
seen anything like i see now in the
climate in this country
so to all the people watching across the
country i say don't be afraid
it's your truth don't be afraid speak up
we have to take it back that's what
they're trying to do is to shut us down
by intimidation and we need to stand up
for what's right we need to stand up for
our rights
we're driving free speech on our
campuses we've talked about diversity of
training in
iowa and uh we just need to encourage
people to step up do the right thing
and um and and fight back it's worth
fighting we have to fight back
governor ricketts when you see people
get de-platform for
no reason on these big social media
companies i go
back to the time that republicans had
the house in the senate and they did
nothing
they did nothing to rein in big tech i
think they thought they could cozy up to
big tech
maybe get some campaign uh contributions
along the way that didn't work out well
no it didn't and when you see companies
like facebook actually
editing the wall street journal like
that is a that's
wall street journal like that's been
around forever right isn't that like a
regular mainstream kind of news source
that's a real one right
and their facebook thinks they should
edit the wall street journal
i think what we have to do is recapture
the house and senate the presidency and
then there has to be regulation on these
companies at a federal level
because what they are doing is making
decisions
that have impact all of us they need to
be treated more like the utility that
they're acting like
governor abbott you agree completely uh
i think that
these high-tech companies social media
companies they need to lose
their exemption protections matter
right but we're working on a bill in
texas
sb12 uh that will allow individuals
who've been de-platform
to sue these high-tech companies to get
back on it's structured in a way
that will avoid the preemption that
these high-tech companies think they
have
so texans will be empowered to sue big
tech
to get back on the platforms all right i
want to get to another issue governor
desantis
um the issue oh actually we're going to
go to a question first then we'll go to
that other issue
charles hart from orlando right here in
orlando has a question charles
well first off governor i'd like to
thank you personally for keeping florida
free
a question i'd like to ask though is
this is many people are beginning to
believe that america is no longer
exceptional or great
so what can we do to reinvigorate the
belief
that america is too great for small
dreams
well i think it's a great question and
uh i was very disappointed after the
2020 election
but i told people um when you're when
your back's against the wall americans
respond
and i think we're responding here in the
state of florida not only are people
coming from all over the country
to live here to visit here i get
correspondence from people
in other countries in europe saying
we're now looking to florida
as the focal point of the free world
because they're suffering under the yoke
of lockdowns so we have the ability to
lead here
people in florida have responded in
people throughout the country and even
i mean very humbly to see this
throughout the world so i think we're
doing it right i think greg and kim and
all these governors
are doing it right and we will have a
resurgence of freedom in this country
and 2022 i think is going to be a great
year for us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else